frankreich befindet sich quasi in einem
doppelten ausnahmen des umstand ab heute
gilt nämlich der spricht der laufbahn im
ganzen land alle geschäft der alle
restaurants alle bars haben geschlossen
und die menschen dürfen nur noch eine
stunde pro tag an die frische luft ihre
häuser ihre wohnung verlassen und
gestern der anschlag bier in der
basilika notre dame hinterm hier an dem
ganz schon gehört drei menschen
gestorben bin
gestern abend war die polizei vor der
basilika später dann haben sich menschen
versammelt in kleinen grüppchen haben
kersten haben blumen niedergelegt wir
können mal ganz kurz darauf schwenken
haben ihre kunst gefahren und die
menschen mit denen wir gesprochen haben
haben uns als bild dass sie müde sind
von dem terror der frankreich immer
wieder einholt 2016 die 86 prozent bei
dem anschlag hieß es einfach viele und
die menschen verstehen nicht warum das
immer und wieder ihre stadt ist
was wissen wir bisher über den
russischen täter der bereits
festgenommen worden ist über den
mutmaßlichen täter bei ihm ist noch gar
nicht so viele informationen was jetzt
ganz neu ist das tunesische medien ein
foto des mutmaßlichen täters
veröffentlicht haben vielleicht können
wir das mal einblenden in dem
zusammenhang
er soll 21 jahre alt sein zu lesen soll
über die italienische insel lampedusa
erst ende september oder anfang oktober
frankreich erreicht haben soll ein asyl
beantragt habe vieles bei diesem
anschlag spricht natürlich für ein
islamistisches motiv er soll mehrere
male allah akbar gerufen haben gott ist
groß selbst nach seiner festnahme
was auch dafür spricht ist das gestern
schon die französische anti- terror-
staatsanwaltschaft gestern abend die
ermittlungen aufgenommen hat
jetzt wird natürlich geprüft hat prima
unterstützt tage hat gestern gab es
schon festnahm
ein 47 jähriger mann soll festgenommen
worden sein
es soll wahrscheinlich telefonischen
kontakt gehabt haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren